anyone who fights the ocean drowns in it
look at this ocean it is vast it is deep
it is powerful it is strong anyone who
fights it drowns in it the preservation
of the Quran is like this ocean waves
after waves Muslim men women and
children generations after generations
they come they memorize the preserve and
they pass this text this blessed text of
the Quran to the future generations
anyone who fights the ocean of the
preservation of the Quran drowns in it
and this is how the Christian
missionaries who are fighting the
preservation of the Quran are drowning
in it one after another every single one
of those Liars
is drowning in it because they are
fighting an ocean we have an ocean of
evidence to support the preservation of
the Quran and I will give you some very
quick examples for you to go and look at
there is a website you must visit my
brothers and sisters and that website is
Islamic
- awareness dot-org I repeat Islamic -
awareness dot-org and there is a section
for the Quran go and click the
manuscript section and you will see the
manuscripts of the Quran from the lives
of the Companions of the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu Salam and they run
into hundreds of examples not one not
two not three I am talking about tons of
examples of manuscripts written actual
original copies of the Quran written
within the lives of the Companions the
disciples of Prophet Muhammad who took
this Quran directly from the Prophet
himself we have all those examples and
when we read those copies like I did in
my video one of my videos recently they
are exactly the same as what we read
today so the Quran and his preservation
is like a sea
it's like an ocean a vast powerful
stable wave after wave ocean anyone who
fights it will drown in it
so all those Christian missionaries
every single one of them is going to
drown in this ocean you know why they
are fighting it because they do not have
an ocean like a daughter they don't even
have a river if the Christian
missionaries had a fragment a page of
the New Testament from the life of Jesus
Christ they would ransom their life for
it they would run marathons they would
go around the world parading with the
page telling the world we have a
sentence we have a page from the life of
Jesus Christ how dare you question the
veracity of the New Testament we the
Muslims have volumes upon volumes pages
upon pages chapters upon chapters of the
Quran from the first century of Islam
from the life of the disciples of
Prophet Muhammad written in the pure
Arabic language with which we find
written in our scriptures today but the
Christian missionaries still have the
audacity to fight the ocean the earliest
example of the New Testament Christian
missionaries have is almost 130 years
apart from Jesus Christ it is a small
tiny fragment of the Gospel of John from
the year 150 C II or some say 125 seee
between hundred twenty-five 250 C E now
if the Christian missionaries had a
sentence a sentence coming from the
disciples of Jesus Christ off on their
lives in the New Testament an example of
it a physical copy of it they would run
marathons and they would ransom their
life for it Salaam alaikum